[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado al día
hablamos de lo ocurrido con la empresa
de criptomonedas ftx que hasta hoy sigue
afectando al sector de las criptomonedas
una semana después de su bancarrota ante
esta situación incluso la secretaría del
tesoro de Estados Unidos
más efectiva de los mercados de
criptomonedas tras este repentino
derrumbe del ftx antes de presentarnos
el día por supuesto nos acompaña nuestra
mesa de trabajo nuestra cronista de
economía Daniel arandón Daniela
bienvenida y ahora sí presentamos a
nuestro invitado en el caso economista
con phd maestría estadística de la
universidad libre de Bruselas Gracias
Carlos por estar aquí con nosotros esta
mañana de jueves
Muchas gracias por la invitación Carlos
quiero empezar a preguntándole y dándole
y a nuestra audiencia un contexto de
Este mercado de las criptomonedas porque
este vamos a hablar primero con Daniela
porque creo que tenemos un problema de
audio con con los invitados carros ya
todo y la palabra Dani pero vamos a
contextualizar un poco Entonces porque
este derrumbe repentino en este mercado
las criptomonedas lo habíamos hablado
aquí desde hace mucho tiempo sobre todo
cuando El Salvador el presidente en el
Duque le invirtió millones de dólares en
en en estos activos obviamente en el
bitcoin Pero hay un riesgo siempre no
latente en estas inversiones estas
criptomonedas que no la tiene tanto un
mercado convencionales de de moneda
corriente como lo estamos acostumbrados
a utilizar Sí yo quisiera comenzar con
una un documento judicial que se acaba
de conocer en el que el nuevo CV de esta
empresa de ftx señala lo siguiente nunca
en mi carrera
hizo una falla tan amplia en los
controles corporativos y una ausencia
tan grande de información financiera
confiable como ocurrió aquí y estamos
hablando de una de las empresas de
criptomonedas más grandes del mundo que
pasará con las más pequeñas Ahora sí
Carlos le doy la palabra disculpa por
ese inconveniente del audio Cómo ve lo
que está ocurriendo con lo que ocurrió
mejor dicho con esta empresa ftx y como
ve digamos el mercado de las
criptomonedas en un futuro
que tanto es el riesgo no en este
mercado de las criptas vale mira el
riesgo de las criptas en realidad hay
que entenderlo como cualquier tipo de
activo hay riesgos pero los riesgos
están asociados también a posibilidad de
obtener mayores ganancias lo que viene
sucediendo es que hay mucho menos
regulación de la que existe en los
mercados tradicionales sin embargo lo
que vemos con este exchange que es ftx
en realidad Son son situaciones que ya
veíamos que representaban en los
mercados tradicionales
Entonces eso eso eso es vale la pena
tenerlo en cuenta porque lo que sí lleva
es a una necesidad de regular sobre todo
el rol que están cumpliendo estos
exchanges que vienen siendo el punto de
entrada al mundo de transacciones de
criptoactivos en realidad estos
exchanges funcionan como los exchanges
tradicionales por ejemplo como la bolsa
de valores que te permite en este caso
cambiar
dólares o pesos y comprar los activos
que se transan en ese mundo Entonces
este este tipo de organizaciones
tienen el problema que ya está muy
identificado en la academia y un poco en
la industria Y es que es es un Gateway
es el punto de entrada a este mundo
transaccional pero lamentablemente estos
puntos de entrada no tienen La
regulación que si tienen los puntos de
entrada al mercado transaccional por
ejemplo de compras de acciones
tradicionales claro Cuáles son esas
recomendaciones que podría dársele a la
gente Porque de todas maneras Esta no es
la primera vez que sucede también
sucedió este año con otra que se llamaba
luna y es que cuando surge una noticia
todo el mundo comienza a vender a vender
a vender a vender y esas ventas masivas
lo que hacen es desplomar el activo y
dejar a la gente sin ahorros entonces
hay personas que sí lo saben muy bien y
que están dispuestas a hacerlo pero hay
otras que no y hay otras que que
simplemente llegan pensando que las
criptomonedas los van a salvar y los van
a llevar a la riqueza entonces Cuáles
son esas recomendaciones para para para
invertir en criptomonedas vale estos
estos fenómenos digamos de digamos de en
que hay como manadas fenómenos de
manadas y de contagios son comunes en
los mercados financieros esto Esto no es
nuevo un poco también Existen los sesgos
comportamentales de las personas que que
tranzan y esto puede darse en personas
con bajos niveles de Educación
financiera pero también con altos
niveles de Educación financiera Entonces
es inevitable y lo único es
saber saber muy bien que Cuáles son los
riesgos existentes Entonces yo no puedo
pretender que hacer una inversión un
criptoactivo va a ser lo mismo que abrir
una cuenta de ahorros porque las cuentas
de ahorros en los bancos regulados por
ejemplo tienen un seguro de depósito y
eso es muy diferente al tipo de
inversionista que compra también una
acción Entonces está enfrentando los
mismos riesgos lo que pasa es que con
los criptoactivos tiene el riesgo
adicional de que no es no está tan
regulado como los mercados tradicionales
pero mucho sin embargo muchos de los
fenómenos que vemos actualmente en el
mundo cripto son cosas que ya hemos
visto en los mercados tradicionales por
ejemplo en el caso
x hubo un uso de recursos de las
personas que habían invertido en o
comprado diferentes tipos de
criptoactivos un uso no autorizado de
sus recursos para hacer otras compras
direccionadas por la misma empresa
entonces ahí hay unos problemas de
digamos de la responsabilidad del
Custodio de la inversión Y eso también
Lamentablemente ese tipo de crisis o
problemas
han sido también o los hemos observado
en la en los mercados tradicionales
Entonces yo creo que aquí lo que sucede
es que es la lección que queda es una
necesidad sobre todo regular estos
puntos de entrada estos mercados de
cripto activo ahí quería ir Carlos cree
que una regulación no podría digamos
mejorar y hacer más seguro la inversión
en adscriptos también como lo decía
Janet y eh que pedía una supervisión más
efectiva A qué se refiere con ese
supervisión más efectiva a una posible
regulación en un futuro porque también
como lo decías es algo nuevo que estamos
viendo relativamente en las escribió
monedas como lo veíamos también con la
tecnología que ya pasó a ser regulada
por parte de los estados entonces una
regulación aseguraría más ese mercado
claramente La regulación genera unos
mejor un mejor ambiente sobre todo para
proteger a los consumidores pero no hay
regulación perfecta digamos que la el
mercado financiero tradicional es una de
las actividades económicas más reguladas
Pero eso no ha sido garantía de que no
hayan sucedido crisis financieras como
las que han sucedido en en la historia
del del sector financiero entonces la La
regulación financiera no es una garantía
La regulación financiera Generalmente
llega un poco tarde y eso no está mal
porque si no no habría ido Innovación
claro entonces este mundo de los
criptoactivos tiene unos potenciales
interesantes y son y ya ya existen unas
innovaciones financieras interesantes
sobre el que son
revolucionarias con respecto a algunos
aspectos de los mercados tradicionales
pero debe de la misma a la misma
velocidad se tienen que mover La
regulación especialmente para para
proteger a los a los consumidores pero
adicional a eso yo creo que también hace
falta un mayor nivel de Educación
financiera en general también
autorregulación por parte de los de los
de los inversionistas y también conocer
un poco Cuáles son los riesgos a los que
me expongo si invierto en x o y activo y
eso y esos riesgos pueden estar
implícitos en este nuevo mercado pero
también existen en los mercados
tradicionales
Pues bueno dos cosas rápidas y es
primero los gobiernos han sido siento yo
que han sido bastante reacios a avanzar
en esta regulaciones y número 2 no
invierta la el dinero que va a necesitar
en un futuro no invierta lo que está
ahorrando para su casa en esta clase de
activos sino plata que no va a necesitar
claro y que todavía pues no está segura
y y y regulado no como estábamos
conversando Carlos Lamentablemente se me
acaba el tiempo lo tengo que despedir
pero igual Muchísimas gracias por
venirnos estudio y conversar sobre este
tema estar apasionante para muchos no
vale Muchísimas gracias